hello thanks so much for a wonderful
talk I know that many philosophical
systems are based in some way around the
idea of maximizing happiness of course
no one really knows what happiness is or
how to really effectively define it I
wonder if you'd have a good definition
of happiness now it's a great question
there there's there's a lot of so
there's actually two different
philosophical questions that you're
raising one is if we're going to be
utilitarians if we're going to think
that what we need to do is bring about
the best outcome what what counts as the
best
so what are we maximizing and then some
people so a March ascends for example
has a has a pretty good answer to that I
think which is well why don't we just
get a list of human goods and we'll try
to bring about the most of those and
we'll just you know talk about what
should be on the list then there's
another question which is what is
happiness what is a satisfying life and
and that's a much harder question I
think and and it seems correct to me
that it's not a feeling but but also
it's a it's a puzzle there's a there's
another philosophical puzzle called the
paradox of hedonism which is similar to
what we've been talking about the
thought is that the more you try to be
happy that you don't achieve happiness
by trying to be happy but you achieve
happiness by trying to do things that
you think are worthwhile and then as you
do things that you think are worthwhile
that satisfaction is a is a byproduct of
of doing the things that you think are
worthwhile
to bring one thing I was curious is you
mentioned in season three how Michael
like finds a problem with the point
system which is that every action has
unintended consequences I'm curious
because I think about this in my own
life a lot like to what degree do you
think we're morally culpable for like
far-reaching consequences of our actions
or like how do you even go about
establishing a bright line I'm just
curious on what your thoughts are so
what do you think but I wait no really
I'm gonna ask her a question back so so
what do you mean by morally culpable
like how morally accountable can you be
held for example if I buy a pair of
jeans and that jeans those jeans were
perhaps produced by like a sweatshop
maybe or they used up like an unusual
amount of natural resources and thereby
like contribute to global warming or
like vice versa
- like what degree can I be held
accountable for those actions like and
yeah I guess that's my question I'm
going to seem like I'm being a pain but
I kind of be like what would I mean do
you mean like to what degree can I give
you a hard time about it
to what degree do you like to what
degree would I be like you if you're if
you're gonna measure like morality
through like consequences like it not
through intentions mmm-hmm
so I mean I guess what I'm what I'm
fussing about is that we can again be
thinking that Oh am i doing a bad thing
right like so so you might be asking to
what degree should I feel guilty about
this you might be asking to what degree
can I have all my friends about this you
might be asking to what degree can we
tax people to fix the problem
I think those are all really different
questions right so so I don't know that
there's one answer to the question of to
what degree am I responsible and
yeah and I think we can make ourselves a
little nuts by thinking you know I mean
they're there they're there are serious
problems that need to be fixed and in
the world very serious problems this is
kind of coming at the side of your
question I'm not directly addressing
your question but but but I think that
there's a real reason to be to be
suspicious of what I think of as the the
putting putting the pressure on consumer
piety right on individual piety as
though that's the way we're going to
solve these problems
consumer like individual piety is not
the answer here institutional change is
the answer right it's my opinion let me
just jump in with a shameless plug here
if you want to take a course on that
question you can walk up the hill next
spring and so in the show there's a lot
of faith concepts that like routinely
interact with philosophical concepts so
like the idea of like demons interacting
on earth with people and like angels
demons I mean that sort of stuff even if
it's not a religious basis like Plato
Socrates like grew up in spaces where
they believed in like tertiary and
secondary influence so like to what
degree does like faith and like faith
concepts influence I guess your work in
like discerning philosophical questions
so I take it you don't believe in demons
no it's a good question
so I I was raised Catholic I spent a lot
of time in different religious contexts
and and I'm no longer I know I'm no
longer in that community but
it's pretty there is a lot of wisdom to
be gained from from the reflect I mean
most of the Western cultural tradition
is kind of seeped in in religion that's
the idea that you could do philosophy
without religion is a pretty new idea so
so I think there's a ton of wisdom to be
to be gained from it and also a ton of
concepts so so in the in the book I'm
writing one of the ideas that I I kind
of appropriate the idea of original sin
because in in contemporary Western
english-speaking philosophy there's the
idea there's an idea kicking around that
is that is autumn flies can so that if
you're obligated to do something then it
must be the case that you can satisfy
that obligation and on the one hand that
seems really compelling to people it
seems like well it's not fair to say
that I ought to do something if I lack
the ability to do it but on the other
hand I think it's really weird to think
that autumn plies can I mean if you
think about most of the obligation the
obligations of being a parent the
obligations of being a good police
officer the obligations of being Dean
these things don't adjust to the
abilities of the individual in the role
right I mean if somebody's too selfish
or too weak of well or too self-absorbed
to be a good parent or a good police
officer they're just gonna do a bad job
all right and other people are going to
suffer and that's so so that's the kind
of thing I call original sin right that
people are the process of personal and
moral development is a contingent and
hazardous affair and sometimes people
reach adulthood without the personal
equipment required to do what they need
and and so that idea is present in the
religious tradition and and it's kind of
there for the for the taking
in an interesting way you mentioned
earlier that kind action requires this
motivation of alleviating the burden of
someone else . I'm wondering how you
feel about the actors obligation to
engage with the unintended positive
consequences that maybe was not part of
their intention but you know may come as
a result of doing a kind action and if
that actor needs to reject that or if
they are allowed to enjoy the positive
effects of doing something kind that's
very interesting so you're worried so
you're worried that if I do something
kind and then somebody like thanks me
and like takes me out to dinner or
something that maybe I shouldn't maybe
be like no that's okay yeah yes so
insane that that it that there are
certain motives that would spoil
kindness like the motive to stay in the
good place I don't mean to be saying
that it's important to never enjoy
things or to only only ever be
other-directed in fact I think it's a I
think it's an interesting feature of a
Canon of philosophy that has not had
women in it that that the worst thing
the worst way you could possibly be as
selfish right whereas once you expand
the community of voices you find people
who say no there's another thing you can
be which is too too much of a doormat
too much there's another way of going
wrong which is to basically to not be
selfish enough and so I think you know
we need we need both we need to properly
balance this I think we'll time for two
more quick questions
so we're reading the Republic in class
and in the Republic Plato seems to have
this idea that society really needs to
be organized in a very particular way
for the prolongation of a good moral
world and good moral humans and you had
mentioned that to some extent our
individual's morality is determined by
social institutions so how much
flexibility do you think there is in the
organization of a society can we have
various types of governments various
types of cultures religions and still be
moral or are there some boundaries that
we absolutely need to adhere to in order
to form a moral Society great question
I'm just giving you my my own answer and
my own answer is what what you need is
something like equal respect and once
you get equal respect for persons you
can do whatever you want so so there's a
lot of variation a lot of room for
change but but not room for oppression
not room for domination final question
so over the course of the good place the
show covers different philosophers and
ideologies like they go through Conte
Aristotle etc are there any specific
philosophers or philosophies that you
would like to see on the show either
because you think it would be
interesting to portray in narrative or
because it's a philosopher's philosophy
that you think that should be spread to
a wider audience they've done a pretty
good job of of covering a lot so they
have been touching on existentialism I
think it'd be fun if they if they played
a little bit with bad faith so bad faith
is an idea from start the way I like to
illustrate it as not the way he
illustrates it but but it goes like this
so suppose you have a good friend your
good friend as a smoker she has been
trying to quit she's tried to quit five
times in the last seven months you are
at a cafe you're not in Los Angeles
because you can't smoke there but you're
somewhere where you can smoke and and
she looks at you and she's like that's
it last one and you're like you're a
good friend so you're not being a jerk
about this but oh come on
really like this is what the sixth time
in seven months like you know be real so
you so here you are you're accusing her
of what Sartre would call fleeing her
facticity into her freedom she's
pretending that she can just declare
that she's quit now imagine your friend
says oh you're right you're right you're
right you're right
I'm a smoker I'll always be a smoker
that's it
she's now switched to the other form of
bad faith
she's now freeing her freedom and to her
facticity so starts idea is that we've
got to find a way to to not do either
one of those things to live well as
people who are both free and embodied
and I think that would be a fun a fun
thing for them to pick up on so with
that thank you very very much for your
conversations let's give them a hand
please
[Applause]
[Music]